confirmation hearings begin this morning
for supreme court nominee katanji brown
jackson now if approved the federal
judge would be the first black woman on
our highest court leaders from both
parties say they want to keep things
civil but some republicans are
previewing a line of attack nicole
killian is in the hearing room where
it's all going to happen a little
hamilton reference there nicole but it
is a room where it's going to happen
nicole good morning to you
absolutely gail good morning to you
these hearings will last for four days
but today is really all about
introductions judge jackson will be
seated just behind me where she'll
deliver an opening statement then she'll
be questioned by senators starting
tomorrow and a white house official
confirms to cbs news that president
biden and vice president harris are
expected to watch some of the
proceedings
i'm pleased to nominate judge jackson
less than a month after president biden
nominated the first black woman to the
supreme court
judge katanji brown jackson will make
one of the most important cases of her
career to the senate judiciary committee
and if i'm fortunate enough to be
confirmed as the next associates justice
of the supreme court of the united
states
i can only hope that my life and career
will inspire future generations
of americans
the harvard law graduate and mother of
two currently sits on the d.c circuit
court of appeals she has also been a
district judge public defender and
served on the u.s sentencing commission
this the last one this week judge
for weeks judge jackson has made the
round on capitol hill meeting with 44
senators from both parties
she's also been participating in moot
court sessions with white house staff
she's going back through her college
career her law school career she has
done all the due diligence on herself
that these senators should be doing how
is this one different it is different
illinois senator dick durbin chairs the
judiciary committee how much pressure do
you feel to get this right i feel some
i'll be very honest with you i want to
do this in the right way
i also think the committee's not on
trial but the committee's being watched
closely
republican josh hawley has signaled he
wants to use the hearings to go after
jackson's sentencing record this is
someone who has consistently let sex
predators child sex predators off the
hook
this attack that we've seen over the
last couple of days relies on factual
inaccuracies and taking judge jackson's
record widely out of context in an
exclusive interview on face the nation
minority leader mitch mcconnell said he
hasn't made up his mind the
committee will ask her all the tough
questions i haven't made a final
decision as to how i'm going to vote
judge jackson was confirmed for previous
judicial appointments three times by the
senate on a bipartisan basis chairman
durbin tells me he hopes that this time
is no different and expects a
confirmation vote by easter tony
all right nicole thank you very much